one of the interesting things about the
multiverse is that it raises questions
about probabilities that we still don't
really quite know how to answer the
issue is that everything that is allowed
by the laws of physics happens in an
infinite multiverse an infinite number
of times so for example you might want
to compare the number of births of
one-headed cows with the number of
births of two-headed cows and you'd
naturally think that there are a lot
more one-headed cows than two-headed
cows but if there's an infinite number
of both one really needs some way of
regulating things in order to be able to
talk about what's the ratio of
two-headed cows to one head cows the
current status of things is that we can
devise ways of regularizing these
probabilities of turning the infinities
into finite ratios but they're different
ways of doing it there's no unique
solution and it even turns out that some
of the simple things that you might try
turn out to give results that are very
crazy sounding so we think that we have
narrowed down a range of possible
prescriptions for defining probabilities
but we still don't know the answer to
what is it that actually determines what
are the correct probabilities in the
context of the multiverse